this is a search for marine life off the
Marshall Islands nearby nuclear testing
at Bikini Atoll made this an unsafe spot
no 1940s when it was deemed safe again
in the mid-1990s special pressure
protective cameras were sent deep
specifically to find sharks which are a
partial indicator of a healthy marine
ecosystem mewho 2,500 feet down a
sixgill shark grabs the bait at the end
of the camera it's thrashing stirs up a
huge cloud of sand the six kill so named
because sharks usually have just five
gills has a lineage that predates the
dinosaur sixgills can grow up to 15 feet
long and can die as deep as 6,000 feet
they're almost never seen and even
though they've been on the planet longer
than we have we hardly know anything
about them let's send our cameras even
deeper and see what shows up now we're
in a body crushing 5,000 feet look
there's a chimera a mysterious predator
also called a ghost shark that's related
to both sharks and rays hey wait a
minute
could it be an even rarer Pacific
sleeper shark pacific sleepers can grow
up to 25 feet long the really cool fact
about these creatures is their flesh it
has a toxin in it that produces symptoms
of drunkenness and humans who eat it
amazing the things you can find when you
go this deep in the ocean